o resultado de casado
além disso pelo menos como a mais bonita
eu sou professora financia e hoje está
em uma confecção a fazê lo
eu tenho uma enorme dificuldade em pôr a
15 anos
é uma espécie de antologia é de que o
génio de vergonha que as mães sentem com
19 de junho de 2010 a jornada e esta
minha convicção em relação à filosofia
faz com que eu muito difícil - tem hoje
menos diretamente e que é muito raro de
ver qual é membro da união é nossa voz e
é verdade que fui atendida por
esmagadora maioria como sendo uma área
teórica abstrata desligada da realidade
uma coisa pra gente o que cada um deve
saber ler
sálvaro e que ainda por cima sem pensar
acerca daquilo que eu já pensava
por isso tenho hoje gostaria de trazer a
ferramenta por ciência da filosofia à
razão humana não é razão entendida no
sentido clássico unificada com deus
apolo onde os alunos da retidão da
sobriedade de equilíbrio em contraste
com a imagem do deus bonízio o deus das
remoções das paixões das centenas
sensíveis dos desequilíbrios entendida
com temperamento é visto de uma forma
muito diferente nos soldados nesta idéia
de deus a bola e sabe que é um homem e
câmbio nesta imagem desde o início ele
sabe que é um cavalo
raj vai aumentar a imagem que ele trazia
essa razão entendida contemporaneamente
um centavo
não sabemos muito bem onde está o homem
nessa prova e esta razão rica complexa
anos no fundo aquilo que há é capacidade
humana pensado nisso
ao contrário do que é costume fazer com
as fantasias e caiu com seguidos erros
três lideranças da razão
comecei a contar uma história tão 1971
inicial é um país da ásia central que
nesta altura estava sob domínio da união
soviética em petróleo e gás natural
então as perfurações tornava uma pequena
aldeia chamada da rasa e quando os
trabalhos em busca de um chamou eu e uma
enorme cratera e os 200 concluiu
quantidades gigantescas de ajudarem
fossem libertadas para a atmosfera tendo
sérias implicações a nível do evento
ambiental e também as consequências para
a população e para os animais
os engenheiros soviéticos na tentativa
de atenuar o desastre ciram conforme era
na sala aimar está promovendo a melhoria
mas em algumas semanas até os netos tudo
esta imagem veio foi tirada em 2015 mas
podia ter se retirado hoje 40 anos
depois a porta para o inferno na criança
estudar continuar e rua cessado a
erradas com adversários mas podia trazer
muito desde o governo discute
vejo até as médicas foram consideradas
estragá las porque não conseguiam
produzir em que falou isso
o que é certo é que a história da
humanidade é uma montanha gil de camillo
nós tivemos quase sempre aos primeira
vivência da casal que realizamos algo
inaceitável
neste momento não vemos há mais tempo do
que nós conseguimos com essa evidência
será que somos obrigados a final das
nossas convicções muito contar as nossas
certezas nós analisarmos enviarmos o
excesso das nossas convenções podem
dizer - uma de duas coisas ou percebemos
que são excessos não são assim tão
sólidos e temos etapas o milagre nos
atualizar os melhorar deus no mar se
realmente perceber que causamos chorar
ou então sou eu diz que essas fundações
são boas e podemos nem que seja durante
mais algum tempo agarrados elas
consideram que este resultado pode ser
parece um campo bom em todos os sentidos
podemos dizer nem que seja muito
desigual no ano
sua evidência nasal sons lixo nenhum
habitar o planeta pequeno à volta de uma
estrela que mais 50 anos
não prefiro uma galáxia que comparada
com outras nada dizia um pouco mais do
que nós conseguimos pensar num enfim
consegui pensar em conceitos como
diversos universos paralelos
conseguimos pensar em suicídio do tempo
e conseguimos pensar no envio de um
sítio uma coisa quando estava em um
sítio onde o facto de estar a enganar
pode ser aquilo que está a fazer
acontecer e nós conseguimos
vivemos a libra cento anualmente a fazer
coisas coisas que não sei muito bem o
que fazer - a fazer coisas algumas delas
para ganhar os 100 dias para
continuarmos a fazer coisas e passarmos
a vida aliada
usamos toda a nossa love está no que
vamos coexistência com ela tivesse o
único voto em curso desde somos um
animal que destroem o seu altar de valor
e ainda por cima com confiança e
passarmos colhida cinco aliados
as coisas na nossa volta nós nos vemos
já temos uma boa estreia está em meu
dever outra vez não consigo mais
interessante é quando essas coisas que
estavam perto de sair da lista temos até
aí a sensação de que estas eram os
amigos quando os prêmios da área e
passar de forma
não só isso então muito província que é
um lixo só consegue ver um ferido passa
lisa olhar para o infinito e ainda por
cima sem vivo na mesa
por isso nem que seja muitas vezes em
quatro anos parado
saiu a evidência do casal estava de
combinados
eu vejo tudo que fazemos está em última
instância a referida nós nos sons
inevitável - no centro sendo que uma
pessoa passa a tua vida
instrumentalizando os outros usando tudo
e todos ao meu redor
no sentido de fazer as minhas próprias
da cidade
eu quero sentir maio ou o menos mau
silva
se for uma pessoa amiga minha vida toda
ajudar os outros é servir os outros
mesmo sindicalista difícil como se vai
fazê lo o filho teria muito mais não
fizesse
quero desistir de viver
achamos entender muito pior que o outro
mas este sendo um fundo e voltar ao
menos dessa comissão como objetivo
sempre vai implicar necessariamente toda
confusa vacinal ea dancinha não existe
sendo 100 pontos
os nossos sabe inventar além dos outros
não acredito que temos que vencer por
nós porque nos filmes famosos
até meus filhos geraldo vistas porque
não temos dinheiro e dirigentes não sei
os outros
segue se um site com sete até aos
significados não forem lançados hoje são
dessa ideia que nos ameaça deitar se
alguma vez se não houvesse ninguém
resposta nós se não houvesse uma única
alma não soubesse que não se esqueçam
essa nossa pesquisa
será que este sinto iluminada conseguiu
cumprir seu objetivo sempre vai por isso
com esta confiança ea importância máxima
nos outros pré cento
vamos fazer é menos respeitado acreditar
ter conseguido trazer 13 crianças a
razão pode estar errado
somos um ser que consegue é muito para
além do tamanho do solo e assim fomos um
centro navas filha se não fossem as
fontes diferença
por isso nós aceitamos estas evidências
ou se dignam a circular e fomos
coerentes na relação aos financiamentos
podemos ter três texturas ensinar a
parar as fitas
eis então o que esta área eólica
avistada desligada da phila fez bonito e
caiu até se nós todos aceitassem estas
conclusões destas lideranças nacionais e
fossem diferentes
seria muito com março no sentido lado
pra lá a coisa mais fácil ao crédito a
miley da apresentação por aí caí com
mostra é que nunca vai dizer e para a
aula
conta aí como especial deusa
[Música]
quero
o
[Música]
brincar
o
dk
[Música]
meu da plan
o objetivo é
[Música]
é
o objetivo é
[Música]
o
só dá ela
[Música]
ah
chora
[Música]
ah
law é
o artigo é
[Música]
o
a enquete boy é com foi a boy
o rio grande achamos normal
[Música]
gelman e logo acredito voz parece um
gesto se parece com o colega e um homem
por igual ao cigarro mas tal de andré
mas será o futebol do meu cargo dos
encargos do mel
eu vejo você quer vencer com bons
a mulher no entanto seu quadro
na guerra afegã senado romano na que
depois a gente mede diversa nos
preocupam
eu entendo o problema das mulheres
deslocados
será desligado
vocês eram investigados por trás está em
uso em parte para a escuridão na cidade
de coxim
então
iguaçu nos táxis e das bolsas de valores
o senhor domingo a pensar defendeu maior
média ground aprendam dependam de
estoque do caos
[Música]
o
obrigado bovina